I survived exorcism and this is the
story when I was in high school I was a
teenager that
was up to no good I would skip class I
have some cigarettes drink some alcohol
it was just one day my friend told me
let's have a cigarette he handed me a
bottle of pineapple juice and said this
would really [ __ ] you up it didn't feel
like anything until I went to first
period when I got to first period I
started seeing blurred vision and I had
stomach pains
felt like somebody was grabbing a
machete and stabbing me in the stomach
repeatedly all I remember was just
turning back and looking at one of my
classmates and I was just like I'm I'm
in trouble I can't see anything I'm I'm
blind I'm going blind
that class ends and I was walking with
like a totally blind person my arms out
I thought it was just something that it
would come and go and I blacked out
turns out that pineapple juice had
rubbing alcohol now this next part might
sound insane the doctors called my mom
and my father to let them know that I
wasn't going to make it I died
all I remember was waking up in a place
that was so peaceful so everything was
so beautiful I saw people that I never
even knew in my in my life my grandpa
and my grandma there my loved ones
[Music]
I'm saying it wasn't my time yet
I remember from that day I was waking up
in the hospital and seeing shadows that
weren't there scenarios that felt so
real doctor just shocked my parents were
shocked and that's only the beginning of
the story
and these voices kept coming months
after I was released from the hospital
he's the more I try to ignore the
the voices they became screams of just
people in pain
drove me to the point where I was afraid
to go to sleep because I every time I
would go to bed I would see myself out
of my body my soul would just be
lingering around my body and these
shadow people would still be there
I was just terrified I got to the point
where I felt completely drained so I had
to ask my mom for her health I told my
mom I was like I've been seeing my body
my soul's been out of my body and I've
been seeing him laying down and I've
seen these people around my body my
mom's an extremely religious person so
she decided to take me to church as a
spiritual guidance
what they call it spiritual guidance
some of you may know it as an exorcism I
didn't want to seek help you know when
you're a 16 year old you're rebellious
you keep stuff to yourself I didn't want
to be seen as a crazy person I didn't
want to be put in a mental institute
some of you hear exorcisms and you guys
automatically think what you see in
movies
it's not that
there's no holy water being tossed at
you there's no screams there's no
levitating chairs there isn't any of
that
exorcisms are not allowed to be
practiced in the United States
some people do but they do it in the
download I remember immediately the
moment I got to that church my body
started feeling hot all I remember was
they walk me into the kitchen there's a
chair there sit me down at the chair
just the floor felt like clouds and I
felt heavy I felt like I was falling
through the floor and the man proceeds
to open up the Bible and says prayers
and there's the other lady that was
right behind me speaking in tongues all
I remember was just hearing this huge
banging coming from the door just
foreign
ignorable they became so loud felt like
somebody grabbed the sledgehammer and
was repeatedly handing the door
felt like somebody was there to try to
break in
get into me I'm not sure the moment the
prayer was done
really really weird the whole room went
completely silent the guy with the Bible
that was reading the prayers looked at
me and
said you're saved
then when the moment that finish it just
felt like I was myself again
this experience didn't make me more
spiritual but this exorcism had a silver
lining like I recently lost my father
not too long ago I experienced afterlife
I know it's real
so I knew that my dad was at peace so I
didn't have anything to worry about